find the slope of the line that goes
through the ordered pairs 7 comma
negative 1 and negative 3 comma negative
1 let me just do a quick graph of these
just so we can visualize what they look
like so let me let me draw a quick graph
over here so our first point is 7 comma
negative 1 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 this is the
x-axis 7 comma negative 1 so 7 comma
negative 1 is right over there 7
negative 1 this of course is the y-axis
and then the next point is negative 3
comma negative 1 so we go back 3 in the
horizontal Direction negative 3 but the
y-coordinate is still negative 1 it's
still negative 1 so the line that
connects these two points will look like
this it will look like that now they're
asking us to find the slope of the line
that goes through the ordered pairs find
the slope of this line and just to give
a little bit of intuition here slope is
a measure of a lines inclination and the
way that it's defined slope is defined
as rise over run or change in Y over
change in X or sometimes you'll see it
defined as as the variable M and then
they'll define change in Y as just being
the second y-coordinate - the first
y-coordinate and then the change in X as
the second x-coordinate - the first
x-coordinate these are all different
variations in slope but hopefully you
appreciate that these are measuring
inclination if I rise a ton when I run a
little bit if I move a little bit in the
X direction and I rise a bunch then I
have a very steep line I have a very
steep upward sloping line if I don't
change at all in the when I run a bit
then I have a very low slope and that's
actually what's happening here I'm going
from you could either use this as the
starting point or view this as the
starting point but let's do this as a
starting point so this negative 3 comma
1 if I go from negative 3 if I go from
negative 3 comma negative 1 to 7 comma
negative 1 I'm running a
good bid I'm going from negative three
my x value is negative three here and it
goes all the way to seven so my change
in X here my change in X here is ten to
go from negative 3 to 7 I changed my x
value by 10 but what's my change in Y
well my Y value here is negative 1 and
my Y value over here is still negative 1
so my change in Y is 0 my change in Y is
going to be 0 right my Y value does not
change no matter how much I change my x
value so the slope here and the slope
here is going to be what's when we run
10 when we run 10 what was our rise how
much did we change in Y well we didn't
rise at all we didn't go up or down so
the slope here is 0 or another way to
think about it is this line has no
inclination it's a completely flat it's
a completely horizontal line so this
should make sense this is a 0 the slope
here is 0 and just to make sure that
this gels with all of these other
formulas that you might know but I want
to make it very clear these are all just
telling you rise over run or change in Y
over change in X a way to measure
inclination but let's just apply them
just so hopefully it all makes sense to
you so we could also say slope is change
in Y over change in X if we take this if
we take this to be our start and if we
take this to be our end point then we
would call this over here X 1 and then
this is over here this is y 1 and then
we would call this X 2 and we would call
this Y 2 if this is our start point and
that is our end point and so the slope
here the change in Y y2 minus y1 so it's
negative 1 minus negative 1 minus
negative 1 all of that over X 2 negative
3 minus X 1 minus 7 so the numerator
negative 1 minus negative 1 that's the
same thing as negative 1 plus 1 and our
denominator is negative 3 minus 7 which
is negative 10 so once again negative 1
plus 1 is 0 over negative 10 and
this is still going to be zero and the
only reason why we got a negative ten
here and a positive ten there is because
we swapped the starting and the ending
point in this example right over here we
took this as the start point and made
this this coordinate over here is the
end point over here we swap them around
seven negative one was our start point
and negative three negative one is our
end point so if we start over here if we
start over here our change in X is going
to be negative ten but our change in Y
is still going to be zero so regardless
of how you do it the slope of this line
is zero it's a horizontal line